on a décidé ce soir de revisiter ton
émission on va jouer à motus action ou
vérité
c'est parti pour chaque sujet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est très simple et chérif ici voilà
c'est la boule avotus vous allez devoir
eux il va ça va s'afficher dans le bar
kohout des vérités ou des actions
d'accord vous allez devoir tirer une
boule si vous tirez une boule noire
vous devrez obligatoirement répondre ou
réaliser l'action si vous tirez une
boule jaune
c'est bon vous êtes tranquilles d'accord
très bien on va démarrer mois tirer une
boule on va démarrer avec on va démarrer
de bouder bouder attendait une action
moi je garde mes habits et va crever
inquiète pas elle est passée à côté
drague avec de la pâte à tartiner sur
les dents petr loisy on va voir si tu
tires une jaune c'est bon si tu te
renoir le jeu me combe besoin je le fais
sans broncher travel combattirent quand
même c'est de la pâte à tartiner pour
toi alors qu'est ce que je fais hazim à
temps parce que quelques jeunes sur les
dangers la gueule sur les dents à
lembach là c'est bien là où pas mal et
là c'est pas maintenant tu avales pas
elle est gérée merkel
[Musique]
c'est une c'est l'équipe de bfm tv
ouais bah nous apprennent créer un mec
ça fait 45 ans qui habite à côté de
l'autoroute alors ils veulent savoir
comment c'est ce qui a des séquelles du
mois aurez vous questionner le monsieur
a des beaux jours bfm tv aujourd'hui
nous sommes avec roger roger ça fait 45
ans qu'il habite aux abords d'une
autoroute c'est quand il ouvre sa
fenêtre le ton qu'elle est là depuis
quarante cinq ans il habite à côté d'une
auto donc moi c'est roger est-ce que
vous avez des séquelles qui leur a dit
[Musique]
[Rires]
allez à contenu du binôme autorise à
lacets alors je rappelle si vous tirez
une boule jaune c'est bon vous êtes
sauvés si vous dirait une boule noire
vous devez faire l'action qui va
s'afficher l'action va s'afficher enlève
la vérité quelle action ou vérité
attendant c'est parti vous devez laisser
ma fille d'ozzy jarry crs à votre mec à
merde
allez-y ah merde
bon pour être sauvé si c'est ça la magie
tout est bien les goûts il va croire que
c'est kenji d'un coup tu prends tout de
suite sont l es tu va rédiger un sms
assange dd on attendant la réponse
vas-y eelv à m'insulter parce qu'en plus
on est en guerre alors je vous le dis en
même temps allanon d'amour voilà là ça
démarre bien me dire mais qu'est ce
tarif mon amour mon amour je suis en
train de mon amour je suis sur toi qui
l'a gêné car elle a les boules
kinomap noir
[Applaudissements]
on va attendre on va attendre la réponse
à l'équipe fanny bon voisin bon allez
avoue action ou vérité
regarde moi alors s'est passé doit avoir
la même temps alors pour cela c'est pour
cela c'est très simple c'est ça vous
allez vous en mettra dès les séries
annoncé je peux pas faire ça pas après
jeunes auraient préféré comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ap
tu vas mourir voilà à plein d'histoires
dont il fallait à nice c'est la sauce
barbecue
la boule noire d'embrasser sur la bouche
alors que tu en régie à l'origine vous
embrassez qui vous voulez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j ai lâchés dans son sol embrasse moi
j'ai eu des dégâts couverts comme ça oui
bon ça tu vas pas comprendre ce qui lui
arrive
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est génial